I wouldn't blame your being a content
creator as a big element to your gripes
with heres of the Kingdom too much
because a lot of us feel the same way in
fact it's really refreshing to hear you
have these conflicting feelings about
the game because I've been curious for a
while now how the content creators feel
about it I would still love to hear more
of your thoughts in a more focused video
you are definitely not alone Bandit I
would gladly welcome a complete
outpouring of your honest thoughts and
conclus a video where you just ran the I
feel like I was the only person who
sorry actually not an hour video would
be amazing
all right fine but for a warning I do
get a little rambly when talking about
exactly how I feel about games
particularly Zelda games so what I'm
going to do is I'm just going to play a
little bit of the Beloved game that
we're talking about while I'm telling
you exactly how I
feel and we'll see how this goes I'm
just going to keep the camera rolling so
if you had seen my video that I had
released a little bit ago called the
Zelda rant um then you probably already
know my feelings about the game at least
my feelings in general but in case you
haven't allow me to Briefly summarize I
think that it's a very fun game to play
gameplay-wise running around killing
enemies you know it's fun in the same
ways that breath of the wild was fun uh
partially actually mostly because it's
the same freaking world and engine and
enemies and setup and goals and pretty
much everything from breath of the wild
and that was already a fun formula so
this game is fun in the same ways just
you know with the added uh new Ultra
hand and things like that um but it is a
bit lacking and by a bit lacking I
mean quite a bit lacking in certain
other ways some ways that a lot of
people fault me for because you know I'm
just being a crying baby nerd with a lot
of expectations which is fair which is
fair but other ways which are rather
fair I feel across the board ways like
this right here now I'm going to I I'm
actually going to start this video off
by talking about the positive things
believe it or not but this is still in
my intro segment so I'm going to get
this one out for free okay for those of
you who have played breath of the wild
you'll probably recognize pretty much
everywhere or at least 90% of what
you're going to be exploring in tears of
the Kingdom because 90% of it is going
to still be in the very familiar world
of Hyrule the surface whatever you want
to call it in tears of the kingdom and
as you'll probably remember places like
this are where cast is for instance
standing here and
being wellbe cast and having like a
unique quest line for you I forget what
it is in breath of the wild when he's
standing here but it's like a hero's
treasure thing he's got a song anyway
clearly this entire area right here was
built around that now in ter of the
Kingdom this is a recycled area Cass is
no longer here in fact Cass is who knows
where Cass is but Cass is no longer here
and all we really get for retreading old
ground is a
cororo anyway but that was just for free
all right that was for free just because
I happened to log into my game standing
here I'm actually going to start out
talking about all of the positive things
about the game of which there are many
and I have a little outline over here to
at least keep myself at least somewhat
aligned with what I'm trying to say so
starting out with the good things how it
felt to play in the sky that's what I
have written down number
one this right here just this this is
what feels like a new game this is what
feels like tears of the kingdom and this
is what is a ridiculous amount of fun
oops I'm about to fall off while I'm
talking here every island that you see
off in the
distance there's no secret sauce for
there's no there's no like you see all
those islands all the way off over there
or maybe that one or maybe there's of
course I don't think there's anything
above my head as far as another island
is concerned right now but that one like
right way over there like how how am I
supposed to get over to that Island
right you might ask yourself there is no
secret sauce you just learn the game and
the mechanics that the game has brought
to the table and you figure it out for
yourself you use your new abilities to
build ridiculous vehicles or whatever
and and make it there on your own and
that is phenomenal it took the
exploration of breath of the Wild
Whoopsie I don't know if I've gotten
this cororo here have I gotten this oh I
have okay it took the exploration of
breath of the wild and just multiplied
it by having you not have ground in
between where you're trying to get
because on the surface of Hyrule as
complicated as it gets is just trying to
climb up like a mountain or something
and not having enough stamina or maybe
it starts raining and then you fall down
and you can't get to where you were
trying to go that's as complex as it
gets for exploration down in the world
of Hyrule in this game there's nothing
connecting us not only do I have to
figure out probably where to how to
climb up that Island when I get there or
you know whatever but I've got to figure
out how to get over there first and
that's brilliant tears of the Kingdom's
concept is a phenomenal one as far as
just a damn fun tolay game is concerned
and of course one of the biggest changes
if not the biggest change to tears of
the Kingdom from breath of the wild
would be the addition of ultra hand and
the removal of all of the other
abilities that we had in breath of the
wild I don't think I have to waste video
time explaining to you why ultrahand is
so fun to use all the reasons that
you're thinking of in your head all the
things you've created the Unholy
aberration the Unholy Creations that you
people watching have created in this
game with ultra hand and the Unholy
Creations that I've created are all
worth it what more is there to be said
about ultrahand and the other thing that
was a a positive and a negative for this
game but we'll get into that later but
the other thing that I really liked
about this game was the the combat and
by the combat which was exactly the same
as breath of the wild I mean the weapons
all the different kinds of arrows have
evaporated Into Thin Air and now what
you do is you fuse them with whatever
you would like to shoot and if you want
an elemental arrow that means you fuse
them with an
elemental piece of equipment or gear or
whatever and that's cool because now you
can do a lot more with that now you can
have weapons that have base uh uh Buffs
like for instance a zoraa spear will
always have the buff called water
Warrior which means that if it gets wet
you see now you see how it's at 66
damage there with its infusion now if it
gets wet it is at 132 and that's really
cool the ability to just I mean their
ridiculous appearances aside like you
know this freaking fire heart on the end
of a really crappy looking sword the
ridiculous appearances aside it's a
really cool concept I like the ability
to craft my own weapons that's the end
of the good things that I wrote down so
and I have here written down anything
else question mark before I get into my
complaints about the
game there were a couple pieces of new
music a few some of which are even
memorable so that's cool the kg theme is
pretty
cool obviously the story continuing from
breath of the wild and giving us new
interactions with the characters that we
grew to love from breath of the wild
like sidon and reu uh and unibo those
are really cool I liked that I liked
some of the story
editions I'm really thinking you guys
I'm really thinking I'm trying I'm
trying oh of course the the new areas
right so it is cool to
have I get sad every time I see just how
much empty space there is up here but
anyway I get you know it is really cool
to have new places to go even though it
is largely 90% the same world it's it's
cool to have new places to go and even
though the depths is the same in every
corner if you've been to the depths here
you've been to the depths here if you've
been to the depths here you've been to
the depths here if you've been to the
depths here you've been to the depths
here you get my point but it is cool to
have just a lot more space to just run
around if if any if nothing else right
so that's very cool but before I
actually go into my harsher criticisms
about it let's just talk about the other
powers that we've got real quick so fuse
was always an odd addition to me because
fuse is essentially just ultrah hand
it's the same concept they just they
just dedicated it to its own power for
some reason because see ultrah hand
already
sticks things together in infinitely
right and fuse sticks things together
infuses them into the same item or
weapon or whatever it seems to me that
that should have just been a feature of
ultra hand like fuse should have just
been like a subfeature of ultrah hand
like I don't see why you know this
option that you get with fuse right here
could not also pop up if you're
targeting it with ultr hand it's not
like it's taking up different buttons
with those two Powers just being
extremely similar I almost feel like
they ran out of ideas for powers to give
link and auto bu is just Ultra hand that
saves you time but again it almost seems
like that should have just been a
subcategory or of ultrah hand I I think
that they should have had bombs make a
return as an ability both square and
circle I mean that would have taken up
this slot and that slot right there
because Square bombs were like the
greatest invention in breath of the wild
that they they were okay bombs that
would sit where you put them I mean
mind-blowing right I think that was one
of the most mind-blowing things about
breath of the wild actually now if you
want to blow something up you've got to
have bomb flowers that's pretty much it
either that or you've got to make some
sort of chemical reaction that I can't
think of off the top of my head and I
know a lot of people are going to talk
about the time bombs because these are
technically The Replacements to the
bombs but look at how large and unwieldy
these things are you know who the these
are not the these are not fair
Replacements to the bombs that we had
and we also can't make them explode on
command anymore they have to be
timed like that it doesn't matter if I
shoot it again it's going to blow up
when it's going to blow
up so the removal of the bombs from
breath of the wild is a very strange
feeling but I I honestly I think they
might have removed them because clearly
they had a focus on removing all of the
you know like glitches and things that
people would exploit about the breath of
the wild engine like for instance
whistle running which you cannot do
anymore people would exploit that in
breath of the wild the bomb jumping
people would exploit that in breath of
the wild so I think that I I think that
they removed those probably directly to
combat those exploits for movement that
people would uh I mean everybody used
them I used them but anyway I will
summarize this little bonus segment of
talking about Link's abilities by saying
I like this one I really like this one I
surprisingly really really like this one
these two should have been part of this
and we should have had our bombs back
honestly like energy based bombs that
you can decide when they they blow up
one of which is a a cube should be a
staple of the Zelda series and that is a
hill that I will die on they should
reappear in the next game and that is a
hill that I will die
on okay with all of that aside as the
Sun is
setting thematically it is also setting
on the positive things about the game
and you might be wondering Bandit you
were being positive this whole time yes
yes I
was so let's get into it speaking of the
sky islands which we are standing on we
are standing on perhaps the most unique
one of them all you remember how just a
few minutes ago I pulled up this map and
I I took a look at it and I was like oh
wow look at all that empty space
yeah yeah look at all that empty
space when when I first started playing
this game I was oh boy I was oh boy I
was excited I mean everybody was right
and this is where you start spoiler
alert sorry if you didn't know that I
don't know why you're still watching
this if you didn't know that but this is
where you start and it kind of teaches
you how to play the game the same as the
great plateau in breath of the wild and
then you make your first descent down to
Hyrule and you you excuse me you ascend
your first Sky View Tower you go up in
the sky and you get your first piece of
the map and it's empty it's all empty
except for that Island were already on
but you think to yourself okay that's
fine there are other places in the sky
that are going to be much more cluttered
I'm sure much more densely packed with
with sky islands and content in the air
I'm sure and little by little every time
that you go up a tower or at least this
was my experience every time you see
something like
this just two or
three and that's it and your your your
heart begins to sink little by little
and not only are there
really not that many sky islands in the
game where there should have been like
it should have been mostly new sky
islands in tears of the Kingdom because
that's what really feels like a new game
and that's what's really fun not only
are there pra like basically not any but
a lot of them are just copy and
paste This Island right here this little
quadrant thing with the little
quadrants okay that's one of the only
unique ones there because it also has a
temple to deal with oh look there's the
quadrants oh look there's a
quadrant oh look there's a piece of the
quadrant oh look there's another
quadrant oh wow look is that is that
what is that a quadrant another quad
quadrant wow oh look there's more
quadrants like in every single corner of
the map there are copy and paste islands
and there are copy and paste like
platform Islands there are even a couple
copy and paste Globes oh and even the
the
flying the flying labyrinths they
literally just took and and I don't know
if you can see like like just blink back
and forth but these flying labyrinths
which are just flying for no freaking
reason and which are just they they are
duplicates like literally you pull up
this Labyrinth object file in something
like blender 3D and just contrl C and
contrl D I'm sorry I forget how to
duplicate in blender it's been a couple
years now but you just duplicate the
entire model and put it in the sky and
that's what they did with these and they
and then they were like you know what
that's cool that's content this is cont
content this is content that people are
are asking for in tears of the Kingdom
absolutely and there are a few unique
islands in the sky there's the great Sky
Island there's the two temples there are
the two temples up here and their
Associated
Islands there
are the bra the bravery and courage and
you know those islands where you you
fall down even though they're all really
similar to each other with the whoopsie
with the same Concepts um but there are
and then of course there is the
Thunderhead Isles which again leads to a
temple so there are the three Temple
leading is Islands the great Sky Island
the quadrants the Spheres the copypaste
labyrinths and the falling
islands and honestly I think I've just
summed up oh and the copy paste platform
summed up all there is
new in the sky now I'm I'm not trying to
like stomp my feet on the ground and
bang my fists on on the desk and just be
an absolute child about things and just
complain because I wanted more blah blah
blah but I I am going to do that a
little bit actually because listen this
was a $70 game okay this this was a $70
this was a new experience that was being
sold to us you want to know what they
did in their last $70 game or $60 game
or whatever all of that
all of that okay and you cannot tell me
that they ran out of ideas for Sky
Islands when they created all of this do
you do you want like just recall with me
back and breath of the wild or even this
game if you want how every single like
in this segment right here there are
probably like five secrets in this
segment right here there's probably 12
in this entire quadrant of the map
there's
probably 100 200 that's probably not
even scratching the surface I don't know
how I died there but anyway that's
probably not even scratching the surface
the creativity that we were expected
that that we had gotten used to from
breath of the wild was
astounding staggering I mean it won game
of the year easily because it was
so big and complex and and intricately
detailed and then in tears of the
Kingdom like I keep mentioning the
actual new content that everybody was
excited for was that we were going to
the sky nobody really cared about re
like yes we were okay with revisiting
the same world of Hyrule sure because
it's a big wideopen world and a lot of
us felt like they could have done a lot
more with it because really the whole
world of H hyru and breath of the wild
was sparsely populated but only with
like one of two things a shrine or a
cororo seed basically basically there
were a few other things but basically
that was the overwhelming like that was
their content that they filled the place
up with and so we were we were okay with
a return to Hyrule given that it would
bring more to the table more unique
bosses around the place more unique
items around the place the return of
dungeons maybe there were several
different reasons why we were excited to
return to Hyrule but one of the biggest
things was that we were excited to go to
the
sky and and this is what we
got I don't know how to like I'm not
going to sit here and calculate but I
would be willing to bet just looking at
this and looking at this that the total
surface area of
new actual new content in Te of the
Kingdom actual new land surface area
content would be probably less than
10% probably just just just eyeballing
this right here probably up an absolute
maximum of 10% of the the land volume
that we were used to in breath of the
wild and I know what you're thinking but
bandit look at that that's an entire
other map underneath Hyrule and it's
just as big as
Hyrule well like I was saying earlier in
the
video I I admire Nintendo for keeping
the depths a secret for as long as they
did like I really really admire Nintendo
for like nobody thought even a little
bit that there was going to be another
entire world down down down under and
they hit it they hit it really well and
boom everybody was Subs uh subscribed
wow everybody should be subscribed
watching this but no everybody was
surprised when this happened and and
when we first would fall down in the
chasms and fought giant frog monsters
and whatever like that's a beautiful
thing I'm not going to lie the depths
they could have done so much much more
with so much more and I'm going to go
into this a little bit more a little bit
just just here in a second but excuse me
there aren't even tough enemies down
here like there at the end of the game
you're still going to be running into
like red boblins down here truly
ultimately even though we have these sky
islands and the depths 90% of the game
still takes place right here in the same
hyru and like I was just saying we were
okay with that
we were excited about that even because
there were a lot of new things that they
could have done with this
Hyrule but here's what they did the
towers are back just different in
roughly the same locations but not quite
shrines are back in fact there are more
of them to do and cororo seeds are back
in fact there are more of them to
do literally quite literally the same
stuff from breath of the Wild
they just brought back just a little bit
differently of course the shrines are
I'll be honest
I they had some really fun puzzles in
shrines and breath of the wild and they
have really fun puzzles in shrines in
tears of the kingdom and if I were
to if I were to say which ones I
preferred I'd probably say the ones in
tears of the Kingdom because tears of
the Kingdom's sandbox with ultrah hand
is a lot more open you can just you know
you you can it it's it's truly open you
can combine anything to anything and
really exploit the physics system um so
I I liked the shrines in this game as
far as shrines are concerned but I would
have traded half of these shrines for I
don't know anything else one of the
other things they did do is they added a
whole bunch of
caves but
90% of the same of of the area that
you'll be traversing in this game is the
same Hyrule and 90% of what you're going
to be doing in the same Hyrule is the
same stuff going to a tower solving a
shrine so that was also kind of a let
down oh you know not to kind of
flip-flop back and forth but one of the
other things that I forgot to mention
that was a positive about this game
would be some of the new enemies that
they brought into it I really liked and
notice I said some because they aren't
all new enemies most the vast majority
of the enemies are still the copypaste
enemies from breath of the wild but the
Phantom Ganon
hello those are cool as hell I like I
really really really enjoy uh fighting
those those scary hands the froes were a
welcome Edition and the gleo of course
were a welcome Edition in fact you know
what speaking of gly I'm just going to
go over there and kill the one that's on
the bridge why not but I've got pretty
much nothing bad to say about any of the
added enemies um the bosses that were
new for the dungeons I like them about
as much as I liked the I mean I liked
that they were at least their own
species and their own
monsters um but I mean I I liked them
about as much as you would like you know
the the different blight ganons from
breath of the wild which by the way used
to are are also Phantom ganons and I
know that I previously was praising the
combat kind of for giving you a lot more
customizability I mean look at this I
have a flower Shield like you guys I
have a freaking I have a flower Shield
do you have a flower Shield I didn't
think so unless you do but mine's cooler
obviously because it's my flower shield
and I love my flower Shield I wouldn't
trade my flower shield for the world of
course I can't do stuff like this with
my flower Shield oh I can I actually had
no idea that I could Shield surf with my
flower Shield because typically you
can't when you fuse something on there
but either way I like my flower Shield
it's cool the ability to fuse things is
cool but but here's the other aspect to
that you know how in breath of the wild
everybody was complaining about oh
weapons breaking like everybody was
complaining about weapons breaking even
people who defended that mechanic
admitted that it was kind of a you know
a oh why is my thing blinking stop
telling me where or deposits
are yeah turn off but like I was saying
even people who defended this mechanic
still
thought
you know I just realized that I'm trying
to multitask this and I'm probably going
to suck at
multitasking but here you guys are going
to see the the greatest way to kill a
gly and you're going to be so
[Music]
impressed seriously though why are you
so mad what did I ever do to
you I sometimes try to see if I can hit
two of the heads in one go but that
never really works out for me where you
going here take one of these with you oh
you're too far up oh what's he doing
what are you
doing oh well that's big I forgot how
big that is it's been it's been a while
since I've killed one of
these oh I'm sorry did you die I didn't
notice you were still
alive but anyway it didn't happen in
this fight I was kind of hoping that it
would happen just so I could complain
about it a little bit but when when
you're weapons cuz okay so here's the
thing a lot of people were hopeful that
with the addition of Fusion on your
weapons and the ability to do stuff like
this destroy your fuse material a lot of
people were hopeful that you could
repair your weapons and keep your
weapons and stop them from from breaking
so often and having to say goodbye to
your good weapons and therefore promote
you know a healthier use of your weapons
rather than trying to only use your
weakest ones pretty much all all the
time and trying to save your your big
ones pretty much all the time and never
really using them but that's not the
case your weapons will still break all
the same in tear of the Kingdom it's
just that not only is your weapon still
breaking you also fused something to it
and here's why that kind of
sucks because not only are you breaking
one weapon now you're breaking one
weapon and one material and a lot of
these materials you also need for your
gear upgrades so you're having to spend
not just weapons now but you're
basically it's a double whammy now with
weapons so not only do you yes you do
get to craft custom weapons and that's
really cool but the toll is much higher
now because now you're burning through
your materials and weapons like I'd be
okay if if when you fuse it the material
on the end would break and you could you
could keep the base
weapon that would make a lot more sense
to me but that's just not the case every
everything breaks and the master sword
being able to like fuse whatever onto it
and like it it looks really cool with
the runes but you know kind of
transforming into and taking the
characteristics of whatever you fused
onto it is is a strange touch but it's
pretty cool though it makes sense
because in that way like if I were to
have fused you know a blunt like a mace
thing onto the master sword not only
does he swing it like a mace instead of
like a blade but it can also mine much
easier etc etc so Fusion system for
weapons is a good thing and a bad thing
like I was saying oh yeah and the like
like like the return of the like likes
was pretty cool too I'm not going to lie
but again if you've been in one cave
you've been in them all so it's kind of
they kind of did the same thing that
they did with all of the world and level
design and breath of the wild in uh with
caves and tears of the Kingdom that is
to say is that warm enough okay cool
that's warm enough that is to say they
brought a New Concept in the caves which
is cool it's a cool Concept in and of
itself
can I go down here yes I can it's a cool
Concept in it of itself but they didn't
do that much with it if you've been in
one cave really you've been in them all
now the depths on the other hand like I
said this was a very very welcome
addition to the formula of breath of the
wild that nobody was complaining about
and I'm I'm I'm like 90% sure that they
were inspired by uh Elden ring uh
because if you'll recall one of the
delays was announced shortly after Elden
ring came out and Elden ring has this
phenomenal moment in it I don't know if
any of youall have played it but if
you've been on my channel for long you
know that I am a huge fan of Elden ring
will be covering it when the DLC uh
drops um I've covered it before on the
channel um but Elden ring is a beautiful
beautiful game that I have like nothing
bad to say about really and it has a
beautiful moment in it where you go down
this this elevator in a well and you're
like ooh what little Chasm or or
catacombs is this going to lead to and
it just keeps going down and keeps going
down and then everything in front of you
opens up and you see a new Starry Sky
which is really like just the roof of
the ca of the caverns but it looks like
stars cuz it's all sparkly and it's it's
a whole other world down there a whole
other world and it just opens up and
then like that the text on the screen
pops up you know and it's like uh cofra
River or or I forget you know what what
the area is called but anyway it's a
beautiful moment and I'm pretty sure
that Nintendo was inspired by that with
the concept of the depths now again just
like I said with the wells The Depths
Were A New Concept that they brought up
but didn't do all that much
with and just like the wells if you've
been in one part of the depths you've
been in all of them because there's
always a mine nearby that has zonite and
there are always zonite ore deposits
around that have some really really
really ridiculously weak enemies
guarding it and that's about it I mean
there are a few Unique Kind of quests to
do down here don't get me wrong the
design of the depths is cool but one of
the things that they did decide to do
with the depths that I am cross with
them about and will likely not forgive
pretty much
ever would be in every single mind
there's a chest and inside this chest is
either 100 zonai charges which you will
use to upgrade your zonai batteries or
get
this a DLC or amiibo item from breath of
the
wild just stuck in a chest down here
fans of breath of the wild who picked
this game up which is the vast majority
of people I mean that's why this game
sold 10 million copies in the first 3
days just an insane insane turnout is
because everybody from from breath of
the wild was really waiting and nipping
at the butt to play this game when
that's the only reward for traversing
every corner of the deep deep dark
depths the only reward that you get is a
chest that
has the tunic of the sky in it or
whatever or the Majora's Mask in it like
that's a cool little Easter egg same as
it was in breath of the wild sure cool
to wear around and kind of show off sure
but there's no it doesn't inspire a
drive in you to go and figure out what's
in each chest it's the same stuff from
breath of the wild and and speaking of
the same stuff carried over from breath
of the wild practically everything is
now they did give us from here downward
some new
gear but again that stops right here and
it goes right back to all of the same
gear from breath of the
wild and then of course the ancient
Heroes aspect I read a lot of comments
online asking people why they're upset
that a lot of the armor sets and music
and enemies and gear and and weapons are
reappearing from breath of the wild they
get upset and they say it's a sequel
what did you expect when have you ever
seen a sequel to debut with 90% the same
gear but I'm I'm going to I'm going to
stop talking about I'm going to stop
talking about gameplay stuff now
because that's going to be that's
debatable I mean all of this is
debatable this is all just my opinion
and OB it's I can't believe I've been
recording for nearly an hour now and
it's taken me this long to say hey this
is just my opinion really honestly I
shouldn't have to say that but you know
it's the way the internet is these days
a lot of people a lot of you watching
will respect this as my opinion as you
should and you know even if you disagree
but there are some of you watching this
right now who are just very very very
upset that my opinion differs from yours
and all I'm saying is just just
understand that if you disagree and you
feel differently and you loved
everything that I said that I didn't
love or Wills be saying that I didn't
love that's fine I'm telling you right
now that's fine you can still be my
friend and I can still be
yours take this thumbs up as proof of
that of my friendship because this isn't
something that fandoms should divide
over I'm just but I'm just letting you
know how I feel because I also have read
a lot of comments saying that the
internet is a very lonely place if you
don't find people who agree with you and
honestly I agree so that's why I'm doing
this for you guys to find solace in my
opinion and for me to find Solace for my
opinion in you guys so really honestly
I'm I'm done talking about gameplay
right now because what's more important
than the new the amount of Sky Islands
the shape of the sky islands the the oh
yeah this was a cool addition man I I
wish they had had done more with like
giving link powers in this game because
this was actually really really cool
being able to do what chicaa or I'm
sorry Giga people do but anyway what's
more important than any of this to me is
the
story and damn it that's what they let
me down with the most in this game so
let me start out by saying that tears of
the Kingdom started off extremely
strongly started off with a
bang
this cut scene right here was everything
it was perfect what is that finding
Ganondorf everything was so
mysterious but he's going to say
something here in just a second that I'm
going to really zero in on and I want
you guys to pay attention to because it
was
so just chef's kiss and it could have
been so much more than it ended up
being so this right here is the first
thing that was extremely intriguing to
me
the fact that something could shatter
the master
sword this blade can stand up against
the Triforce by the way can kill a
Triforce blessed
individual in Twilight Princess it's
shown to be able to do that my power
cannot save you from me and that's the
thing like I
agree so what's his power right what's
this new grand power you who carries
that fragile sword this is what I was
talking about this is what I was talking
about can I pause this no I can't okay
so I'm just going to back out of this
because it goes on for quite a while
longer but that right there when
Ganondorf says Zelda and you who carries
that sword are
link listen none of us knew that this
was going to be a closed time Loop Story
by the time when we were just playing
this okay we so when Ganondorf looked at
Zelda and Lincoln recognized them do you
know how insanely cool that felt because
For the First Time it felt like he
recognized them because it was the same
Ganondorf from earlier in the franchise
for those of you who are new to the
franchise from breath of the wild
Ganondorf has been a big baddy since the
days of Ocarina time technically
technically since A Link to the Past
because that's when we had figured out
that Ganon used to be a a man known as
Ganondorf dragmire if you were to have
read the A Link to the Past manual that
came with the game and then in a Karina
of time in 1998 1998 the bad dude
actually Came Out Swinging and man he he
has left a lasting impact on the gaming
world ever since his first appearance
Wind Waker came out and his appearance
just got cooler it was the same
Ganondorf but we're fighting him Untold
years later the original World of hyru
has been swallowed underneath the waves
and he's back he's going to resurrect
the old world because he always wanted
it for his people you know so his story
Got Deep we love Ganondorf then he died
at the end of that game and at the end
of that timeline and in the child
timeline of course he had an appearance
in Twilight Princess a little bit less
to say about him in that game but still
a cool
appearance and then we said goodbye to
him for 17 years and now he's back and
he's been slumbering and creating
ganons this whole time right so a lot of
us were thinking oh this is this is him
from the Fallen timeline he's been here
the whole time he recognizes Link and
Zelda from Ocarina of
Time or from a link to the past or or
from you know A Link Between Worlds or
whatever like he he recognizes them oh
my goodness or or you
know it felt so cool to have Ganondorf
of all people directly talk about the
timeline in a Zelda
game but of course we know that that
wasn't the case he only knew who Zelda
was because Zelda got sent back in time
removed from the situation immediately
exact L like breath of the wild and he
knew Link's name because rahu
practically whispered it in his ear
before he sealed him away for countless
Millennia or however long it was excuse
me which is significantly significantly
significantly less impactful and
speaking of ganondorf's
impact there wasn't any I was just
talking about how deep of a character
Ganondorf has been this whole time and
some of y'all might not have even known
that some of youall might have thought
that Ganondorf was just a stereotypical
video game baddy this whole time but for
a lot of people you know at least the
ones who who like to read in between the
lines and whatever Ganondorf is is
deeper than just that and really
honestly we have his Wind Waker
appearance to thank for that we also
have his aine of time appearance because
the first time he saw link he was
impressed by him being courageous and he
spared the little Link's life then he
grew to regret it of course 7 years
later when link grew up and kicked his
ass so like Ganondorf has always been
like you you you can see him respect
other people you can see him have human
thoughts you can see him have human
nobility like in Wind Waker he's a cool
villain people love him so to bring him
back and also I'm not talking about the
four Swords Adventures Ganondorf because
I mean let's face it four Swords
Adventures lore is kind of weird but
anyway to bring him back but it's a new
Ganondorf and then to give him
absolutely no background or no backstory
at all like literally the first time we
see him is right here
after the start of the game of course
but this is this is all the backstory we
have he's already mad he already wants
to take over Hyrule but you might be
want you might be thinking to yourself
oh that's exactly what he's done in the
previous games right not necessarily he
wanted the Triforce in the previous
games he wanted the ultimate power in
the previous games he wanted the wish in
the previous games in this game he just
wants to take over
Hyrule just because because happens to
see this zonai secret Stone on ru's
wrist just
because it's he has one moment of
feigning depth to his character and it's
at the very end where he says I must
like something like I Must Destroy all
my enemies that is what a king must do
that's as deep as it gets with this
Ganondorf to say that that was a letdown
to say that that was a Monumental
letdown to me would be a massive
understatement because he was one of the
biggest pools for the game when they
revealed that he was going to be in this
game and he had this new design that was
just so Kick-Ass looking I mean oh my
God right but it's just nothing it's
just a big old nothing burger and we can
come up that's the thing about like
talking about the lore of this game is
we can come up with whatever Back
stories we want to as fans but it's all
so
equally it's all just fanfiction at this
point like the difference between
fanfiction and a and a theory in my
opinion is that a theory should be at
least marginally more believable a
theory should be actually you could see
that functioning that way a fanfiction
is just writing whatever the heck you
want just writing whatever story you
want and you know it doesn't necessarily
have to fit with anything and I need to
move on from Ganondorf because I if I
keep talking about the let down and what
they could have done with Ganondorf
will'll be here for forever and I've
already talked a long time and I still
have quite a bit to get through another
problem that had with the story of this
game was the fact that it did not really
follow up on its continuity from breath
of the wild so the biggest and I'm just
going to hit I'm I'm just going to come
Out Swinging with this
point the one of the biggest things
right differences between this game and
breath of the wild is the lack of all
the shik
technology that's not the same Tower
from breath of the wild the towers from
breath of the wild The Guardians from
breath of the wild the shica Slate from
breath of the wild is just gone just
gone and we had a lot of theories as to
why that happened but recently
fujibayashi the director of both breath
of the wild and teers of the
Kingdom came out in in an interview and
really the interview is not new but it
was just released to the public uh
recently um and I say recently it was
probably like a month or two ago at this
point but in that interview he says and
you probably already know what I'm about
to say in that interview he
says
that the shik technology just up and
disappeared and nobody knows
why I don't even know how to go into
that to be honest with you I like I
don't even know how to go into why that
is the
most like I apologize but I don't
apologize why that is the most asinine
explanation of all time like what the
the shik technology just knew after the
Calamity Was Defeated that its purpose
was done fulfilled and so it just
decided okay that's it that's it I'm
going on vacation I've done my duty so I
was just in a uh podcast with uh uh
ratat toar and my and monster maze who
I'm a pretty good friend with and uh you
should go check that out because if
you're if you're down for complaining
about tears of the kingom there's a lot
more in that podcast but in that podcast
we talked about this and monster maze
brought up the point that if the shik
technology was just waiting for Calamity
Ganon to be defeated so its purpose
could be fulfilled then why didn't it do
why did it not do that with the original
Calamity Ganon that the shik technology
was built for 10,000 years
ago you see what I'm saying why now it's
almost because they they just Nintendo
just knew kind of what they wanted to
do but they didn't know how to connect
it to breath of the wild so they didn't
they just didn't and I mean I could go
into a lot more but it it it just comes
down to a whole bunch of things from
breath of the wild just not fitting very
well like people don't act like they
were just under the actual threat of
Extinction like what four or 5 years ago
or however long it's been in between
both games they act like they don't even
know that that happened like do you not
see the world still in Ruins do you not
know how that happened do you not want
to ask how that happened like what what
is going on and then there are people
who just don't remember link and I get
it some people like random NPCs if they
don't remember link really it's whatever
but I'm talking about the people that
are a bit more important to the story
I'm talking about people like
hu you know hu he's the big cororo
dancer dude how many times does link go
to talk to hu in breath of the wild a
lot or all of the cororo for that matter
how many how many interactions does link
have canonically with cororo and breath
of the wild a lot he even canonically
goes and gets the master sword because
he starts tears of the Kingdom off with
the master sword so
canonically as of the Canon events of
this very game he has entered the Lost
Woods and he has met the cororo and the
deu tree and he has obtained the master
sword so why do they act like they're
meeting him for the first time in this
game the first cororo that you go talk
to is like what you can see
me bro I just found 900 of you people I
drew this sword I I come to the Lost
Woods every Tuesday for for for brisket
Tuesdays all right and we we share
meat it's a meat Fest like what what do
you mean you don't remember me do you
see what I mean that just doesn't make
sense it doesn't fit and everybody had a
whole bunch of expectations for for
tears of the Kingdom's new story we were
all a bit tired like it worked for
breath of the wild the way that the
story was all in the past we didn't
really accomplish much in the present
game all we really did was figure out
what had happened in the past oh come on
link you can do it get up the hill but
that's all that's but that worked for
breath of the wild but in tears of the
Kingdom we were all ready for something
new we were ready for something that was
going to
be eye opening and something that we
were going to be able to play through
rather than just kind of figure route
that happened in the past but they did
the exact same thing in this game that
they did in breath of the wild Zelda
gets removed from the scene immediately
goes in the past and lives that whole
time until the present creating all of
the different teardrops around the place
and creating the story that we once
again have to piece together because we
don't get to play through
it it's a tired formula but one that
they copy and pasted because they could
not deviate from the concept of breath
of the wild that was a nonlinear story
they wanted to accomplish another
nonlinear story that you could just do
in whatever order you wanted so to do
that once again they sacrificed a story
that you actually play through with your
own two hands and just like my ancient
breath of the wild review that I don't
even know if it's still on the channel
but just like that one I I questioned
whether it was worth
it for the sake of good storytelling
also anybody who's watching this you
better not dare question my my building
prowess this is the greatest vehicle
you've ever seen and you know
it you can't climb stairs either okay
stop coming at my vehicle I'm just
kidding I know you can climb stairs oh
where do you think you're going you're
not off the hook yet buddy we got
Bridges to cross and all sorts of things
to complain about and again I could sit
here and harp on the story over and over
and over but you get the point right you
get the
point
can your vehicle do that I didn't think
so like I said best damn vehicle in the
world a bomb flower you shouldn't have I
was running out but you get what I'm
saying about the story I mean it it
nothing from breath of the wild was
explained like we still don't know who
the the three dragons are we know that
if you swallow a secret Stone you become
a dragon that looks really really
similar
so you know who swallowed the secret
stones to become those dragons huh since
the zonai are so and we still don't know
who the hell the zonai are where' they
come from are they aliens do they
literally come from off planet and why
did they take an interest in us why did
they leave but why did two of them stay
behind what why why why why why why just
so many things to wonder about but you
know since they're just so mysterious
and all knowing and all sorts of you
know jargon whatever then who's to say
that they weren't like the golden
goddesses aren't zonai themselves and
who's to say they didn't swallow their
own secret stones and become those three
dragons that are clearly named after
them fosh nadra din rol what if that's
literally you know veror neou and din
like that's a ridiculous notion of
course but is it is it really the zonai
are clearly all powerful clearly choose
their own sages clearly can come up with
secret stones that can give people
Powers some people powers that can
shatter omnipotent Rel relics like you
know the master sword like what where's
the
Triforce where where is it we didn't
know where it was in breath of the wild
some people were convinced that it was
in Zelda since you know the symbol
flashes on her hand but I don't I people
like me are not convinced with that
people like me need to know why it's
just resting in her bloodline now
instead of literally being an an
attainable Relic like it's always been
it's only ever rested in people's blood
lens when it was separated when it when
it needed protection it would choose
people as protectors and they would be
imbued with powers power going to
Ganondorf wisdom going to Zelda courage
going to
link if it's all in Zelda's bloodline
now why and and what point is that and
shouldn't that mean that she's all
powerful now because the completed
Triforce grants wishes ultimate wishes
and if it's not in Zelda which I don't
believe it is where the heck is it and
of of course the biggest one how do
these games fit into the timeline do
they even fit into the timeline is this
a new continuity if it is a new
continuity why do some Zora uh writings
reference Princess Ruto from Ocarina of
Time why does creating a champion talk
about ocarine of times events as the
distant past why do we literally see
some of the temples from skyward Swords
spread around in Hyrule and why is
everything that's
everything that's anything that is
anything ever
zi as I was saying in my original rant
video it's like Nintendo was watching
our videos about oh my God don't you
dare you you know what you know no
nobody hurt my vehicles anyway as I was
saying what was I saying where was I
where where what am I even talking about
what what is
anything oh yeah I was talking about the
fact that everything is zonai the
history of
anything is Zoni hell there are even
flashback cuts
on the great Plateau
where the Temple of Time like there's a
Zone ey Temple of Time which in and of
itself is just so weird but in the
flashbacks the zonai Temple of Time was
on the great Plateau where the current
Temple of Time
is and if you don't believe me I'm not
going to edit it on the screen or maybe
I will if I feel like it if you don't
believe me look it up like figure it out
for yourself I'm not lying the zonai
Temple of Time was where the current
Temple of time is is and the current
Temple of Time I
guess was built afterwards in the same
spot by hens for some
reason why I don't know I don't know
everything is so hard to explain because
nothing is nothing is explained and
everything is Zoni which is just the
dumbest explanation and the most easy
one that you could ask for and I don't
know a single person who's satisfied
with that who actually cares about the
story and what it leads to is everything
being
just so gosh darn uninteresting
now everything nothing like
nothing matters
anymore and it's
sad don't you fall off don't you
freaking oh you
did it's okay I still love you I still
love you but nothing really matters
anymore and you can like it might matter
to a few of you watching watching this
but literally just look up like Google
Trends or look at look at the amount of
of lore videos being posted about this
game as opposed to before the game
released like it has completely killed
the hype behind wanting to know what's
going on in this universe because it
doesn't matter anymore because
everything is so convoluted it's either
way too complex to explain or it's not
explained at all or
both somehow both It's A New Concept
that this game invented I don't I know
you guys I feel like I've I've
sufficiently what
the
Iona
aona I guess I had left aona here from
uh who knows how long ago but a hi girl
hey such a good girl just staying there
not moving a single inch from where I
left you I was always coming back for
you I swear where I was don't you
believe anything else don't you dare
believe anything else and see now that
now that I'm riding on top of a pona I
have to I have to change stuff around
hold up hold up this is
tradition this is tradition there we
go this is right this is
right and if you don't see the value in
this right here then I don't know what
to tell
you but anyway I could go on and on and
on and on but I feel like I have in in
this little ramble session I say little
but
it honestly if you've made it this far
congratulations you asked for this so
here it is I think what I want to do is
I want to talk about why this happened
like why why tears of the Kingdom
released and people got disappointed in
it like why why why was tears of the
Kingdom created this
way well to be honest with you I think
that I think that the success of breath
of the Wild and the style of game that
breath of the wild is has a lot to say
about why tears of the Kingdom came out
as essentially a copypaste version of
that
game see right after Sky's sword
released if you remember those of you
who have been in the franchise or in the
phandom for that long a lot of people
hated skyd
sword and you know it's kind of it's
disappointing of course because skyed
sword is a really good game
story-wise but gameplay-wise it was a
bit lacking not many people liked the
mechanics with the motion controls not
many people liked the backtracking that
you had to do to get through places or
to go back to the same area to do the
second dungeon in the same area and when
you were just trying to do that to have
like a segment where you're captured by
the goblins and they take all of your
stuff like no nobody nobody liked that
right or the people who did are very
very few and far between so Skyward
Sword was was complained about quite a
bit and Nintendo if they've ever done
anything it's they listen to the fan
base now they might not always come up
with very good
Corrections based off of what they read
from the fan base and sometimes they
overcorrect but if there's one thing
they do it's they they listen to
feedback they've done that with all the
previous Zelda games Wind Waker was too
cartoony and so they went the complete
polar opposite way with Twilight prin
and made the most
dramatic realistic looking Zelda to date
in fact in the files for Wind Waker oh
is there like an army up here I don't
really want to fight an
army but anyway in the files for Wind
Waker or for the Twilight Princess it's
called Wind Waker 2 like seriously and
it has the Wind Waker object in there so
it was supposed to be a sequel to Wind
Waker but they listened to fans and
thought you know what what they want is
something more mature so after Skyward
Sword the biggest complaint that they
could hear was that Skyward Sword was
too l
linear too trapped into going here at
this point and going there at this point
and whatever so in breath of the
wild they completely released everybody
so that you can do exactly what you want
to do when you want to do it doesn't
matter when doesn't matter where go in
whatever Direction the only thing you
have to do in breath of the wild is
complete the great Plateau segment after
that after you have your parag glider
who knows the world the world is your
oyster crack it open the biggest and
most popular Zelda game to date when you
take into account the 3D release of it
as well or 3Ds release of it as well is
aine of time besides the the breath of
the wild and onward so before breath of
the wild it was aine of time right Zelda
games had been living in ocarine of Time
shadow ever since and every game after
that was an ocarine of time like game
and then breath of the wild came out
reinvented the wheel and they were very
much so rewarded for it I think Ocarina
of Time plateaued around 14 million
sales across all versions breath of the
wild is above 30 million currently so
this nonlinear break works right so
Nintendo did exactly the same thing with
tears of the kingdom and they didn't
want and and that led to all of the
complaints that I've been talking about
with the story and whatever
personally I don't see a problem with
doing that necessarily
but I think that they could have handled
it a lot better I think they could have
written a story that was more cohesive
with breath of the
wild I think I don't think it's that
some people act like it's so difficult
to maintain a nonlinear open world
format and write a good story like I
I've literally read comments that are
like I don't know what you want from
them man like I don't know what you want
Nintendo to do like do you want a good
game or do you want a good story you got
to choose why do I have to
choose why why is it that difficult is
it that difficult to write a story that
that that meshes with its own previous
lore news to me and I disagree I
fundamentally disagree because if it was
that difficult then the fans wouldn't
come up with such great fan theories and
fan stories that are all significantly
better than anything that happened in
this game and I think they should have
taken a lot more care into
characterizing the new characters that
they came out with like for instance
I I don't care about the ancient sages
especially after those
ridiculous God awful copy and paste cut
scenes from can can you actually rewatch
them
here no I don't think you can those copy
and paste Cuts scenes every time you
finish a dungeon you know what I'm
talking about I don't even know what to
say about those to be honest with you
because it's like that's just ridiculous
like that is that is just
asine to release a game where multiple
actors say the same lines about the same
concept Demon King secret Stone secret
Stone Demon King Demon King secret Stone
literally
literally asinine asinine that that is
so far below Nintendo expectations that
I I'm I'm very disappointed and I will
probably never forgive them for that
one so clearly they should have spent
more time crafting a good story rather
than coming up with what they wanted to
do with the gameplay first and then
trying to fit a story in around that
they should have come up with the new
story first and then tried to fit the
gameplay around
that they were already going to get the
sales it's the sequel to breath of the
wild and speaking of new characters I
feel like they should have introduced
more new characters I don't think that
bringing Ganondorf back was a good idea
I'll just be honest with you I think
that the series has been screaming for a
new villain for a while like why is it
that Nintendo had to Outsource the
breath of the wild prequel game age of
Calamity which is non Canon of course
but hyro Warriors age of Calamity why
did they have to Outsource it to who is
it Konami I don't know who does the hyro
Warriors games but in order to get a new
villain for the Zelda series asor like
the Nintendo team couldn't come up with
the new villain and you know what asor
was pretty cool he was characterized
pretty cool actually to be honest with
you the story of age of Calamity is
pretty cool but again it's it's
essentially a fan story that people just
wrote up and because of that it's
non-canon because see when you create
new characters and you write new stories
for these new characters nobody has no
old weird fans like me have expectations
for these characters all of my
disappointments in Ganondorf were
because he's not as cool as the other
versions of Ganondorf but if it was a
new character why should I complain
about that I don't know to complain
about that you could create a new Bland
character and I'd just be like oh okay
whatever and it would be at the very
worst neutral but now that you've
brought Ganondorf back and made him
Bland now it's a negative you see what I
mean come up with new characters because
then at the very very worst at the very
least they'll at least be uninteresting
but not a negative anyway I I feel like
I've said my piece about this game I I
could I could go on I could write a
script and follow a scripted review but
I just I don't know when it comes to
reviewing games I'm not a professional
I've not really done this that much in
the past so I felt like just turning the
camera on and just talking to you guys
if that works and if you're still
watching this right
now you know what just like with the
Zelda rant video I really am not
expecting anybody to still be watching
this oh I don't have a bow of course but
if you are still watching this right
now leave a comment saying shoot that
whiz
robe no don't leave that comment say say
nice shot if you're still watching the
same a nice shot then I'll
know then I'll know but anyway I if you
are thank you for still watching I I
just after reading the feedback in a lot
of the comments from my Zelda rant video
I just I knew that I had to do something
like this and I had to just level with
you guys about how I felt about this
game and kind of explain
more about my thoughts behind my
disappointment with tears of the Kingdom
look a Restless Cricket I wonder where
I've seen that look A
Soldier oh look he's dead I wonder where
I've seen these people from look a
duplex bow I wonder where I've seen that
from before you get the point you get
the
point so with that you guys I feel like
I've said all I need to say I feel like
I don't need to go into this subject
anymore I feel like I have explained my
thoughts behind the Zelda rant
video and just reiterate and recap I
mean you can still go watch that video
if you want more of me r rambling I
don't know why anybody would want that
but if you want more of rambling you can
still go watch that video but just to
reiterate what I said there I am I'm
probably not going to be covering tears
of the Kingdom exclusively anymore in
videos at all I'll still cover Zelda
don't get me wrong but it'll be you know
Legacy Zelda games and of course tears
of the Kingdom will probably come up in
those videos but this is not going to be
a tears of the Kingdom channel it's not
going to be a breath of the wild Channel
this is going to be a gaming lore
Channel like I've always wanted it to be
and it's going to
incorporate other franchises Zelda
included and speaking of which let me
know what other franchises you want to
see covered in case you missed it there
were a lot of people who asked for
Metroid on the Zelda rant video I did
start off with a boss lore video for
Metroid Prime so check that out I'm
actually really proud of that one
um and that's it I have here the last
thing that I have written on my uh
little outline over here is going
forward what would I like to see in the
Zelda franchise and that's something
that actually now that I'm thinking
about it I would like to ask you guys I
know I keep asking you to write comments
but listen there's no shame in leaving
multiple comments on my video all right
I guarantee you I read them uh but going
forward what would you like to see from
the Zelda franchise and of course I will
weigh on in on this as well I would
still like to see practically the same
things that I talked about at the end of
O uh breath of the Wild
I would still like to see a return to
dungeons true dungeons not these short
little see I haven't even gone into what
I thought about the
dungeons maybe what I need to do is just
live stream and talk about this stuff
you guys so so maybe I'll maybe I'll
live stream if you guys like that add
that in to your thoughts about the
future of the Zelda franchise if you
would like for me to schedule a live
stream where I talk about just maybe
I'll just walk around in this game and
talk to you guys about it but anyway I'd
like to see a return to dungeons I'd
like to see a return to at least a
somewhat linear story like if the story
was like Skyrim like if if the open
world was like a Bethesda game where
there is the main story line that has to
be progressed
through with the main
characters like and there are but it's
still open world so you know you can
progress as you want to and there are
side quests and whatever I would prefer
that we do that which is really what
Zelda has been since the days of like
aine of time to be honest with you like
that's exactly what aine of time was
that's what Twilight Princess was that's
what Wind Waker was that's what Zelda
has
been honestly I want to see a return to
that just in a world like
this and honestly the world doesn't
really have to be this big again like
they don't need to bust their butts
making a world this big every single
time or bigger they could go to half
this size to be honest with you and that
would be more than enough but I would
like to see a return to oh oh oh Lord oh
no it's a big bad hinox also another
thing that I don't get with this game is
why why there are still regular level
enemies
everywhere it makes it really hard to
find good horns when there are still red
level enemies like all over the place
you know what I mean you know what I
mean well easy peasy I didn't even get
to see his health
bar but you see what I mean this is like
this is the end of the game and I'm
still encountering enemies like
this that to me that's just that's just
that shouldn't happen that should have
been a much harder level enemy with a
lot better loot to be honest with you
but whatever I rest my case so yeah I'd
like to see a return to dungeons I'd
like to see a return to the story or to
the kind of Storytelling I don't mind if
they introduce new things I don't mind
if they introduce something else that
can also break the master sword in the
next game or if they introduce another
blade entirely I don't mind so long as
it's a good story that's
it okay that's it you guys I'm done with
this subject and just in time to finish
my
monster
that's to all of you for making it this
far go enjoy some video games go enjoy
Thanksgiving Happy
Thanksgiving and uh make sure you
subscribe to the channel got a lot more
gaming lore videos to come I'll be
reading your comments to look at
whatever franchises you guys want to see
on the channel and uh yeah we we this is
not the end you guys this is just a new
beginning okay this is the start of
something really really cool oh look
he's looking at his hand I guess that's
one other new thing they added to the
game is a new Idol animation but anyway
this is the start of something that can
be really really cool all of us
venturing off into new franchises
together so let's do it together anyway
Happy Thanksgiving this is Bandit
looking forward to seeing you in the
next one and signing
out
peace